E aí
[Música]
o Olá meu nome é Pedro Teles eu tô aqui
para conversar com vocês de como a gente
pode fazer para aproveitar potency mudar
a cultura de que a gente espera os
nossos trabalhos a forma como a gente se
conecta da forma como a gente pensa
construção de empresas a participação de
empresa a gente tá conversando muito
sobre o propósito de encontrar o que se
pensa de encontrar os identifica e para
mim essa conexão veio muito a partir
dessa mudança de olhar a gente está
acostumado a olhar as empresas com uma
coisa lateral pensar forma que você quer
viver para que a empresa seja só o seu
trabalho seja sua base de uma vida que
acontece dos Domingos uma vida que
acontece no final de semana a gente
precisa dessa mudança de cabeça porque é
dessa potência é dessa transformação que
vai vir muito da solução dos grandes
problemas que a gente tem enfrentado
como sociedade
e as empresas são a segunda maior forma
de organização humana em se organizem
famílias e depois a gente se organiza
empresas são mais de 125 milhões de
empresas do mundo e é uma potência que
precisa estar conectada com Desafios que
a gente tem de momento com desafios da
sociedade que a gente precisa construir
se a gente quiser continuar funcionando
nesse modelo a gente está no mundo que
vem falando sobre Impacto social sobre o
impacto ambiental há muito tempo e essa
há muito tempo ainda não foi suficiente
para que as pessoas virar Se achava na
velocidade que a gente precisa para
resolver esses problemas a gente tá
falando aqui Dos objetivos de
desenvolvimento sustentável a gente está
falando sobre acordos multinacionais
como acordo de Paris e todas as
pesquisas todos os pontos de
acompanhamento dizem que a gente ainda
está muito longe disso e cumprir com
esses acordos de cúmplices
o que os próprios das próprias
organizações os próprios países pensaram
em conjunto A gente precisa acelerar
essa cabeça isso conecta muito com fato
de como a gente pensa nossa vida no
trabalho para mim eu percebi que o que
eu gostava o que me encanta fazer é
entender e trabalhar para que as coisas
do dia-a-dia para que os processos de
construção de empresa para que as
decisões de compra as decisões de
investimento sejam de fato uma força e
um mecanismo a ferramenta para
transformação social a solução de
problemas sociais para solução de
problemas ambientais durante essa busca
enquanto a gente vê por aí umas série de
empresas que já estão fazendo se a
própria inspiração vem trazendo esse
caminho cada vez mais forte para mim ele
começou na tentativa da minha primeira
empresa alguns anos uma empresa que
tinha como objetivo se transformaram
a forma para divulgar outros serviços e
outros negócios de impacto ele inseriu
de vez Nascimento foi nesse ponto que eu
percebi que o trabalho estava sentindo
diferente que as entregas estão saindo
diferente essa conexão está fazendo uma
coisa que eu acreditava fazer a
diferença tava realmente foi trazendo um
resultado diferente eu também na
construção dessa tentativa desse projeto
que no fim se transformou numa empresa
para alguns anos que eu encontrei o
ponto de envolvimento que me trouxe aqui
até hoje na busca por como a gente pode
entender de fato Quais são as empresas
estão trabalhando pelo Impacto que tão
trabalhando na solução de problemas eu
encontrei o sistema B que a organização
que eu trabalho hoje A ideia é que a
gente precisa trazer todo esse discurso
que a gente veio a por anos e anos
trabalhando para aumentar a visibilidade
transformar ele em pra
eu e mais importante de indicadores
sobre isso e ferramentas para trabalhar
esse Impacto porque o momento de
urgência Já chegou faz tempo a gente já
tá atrás desse relógio que a gente tem
que compensar então a velocidade precisa
vir na mesma forma como a gente pensa os
resultados financeiros das empresas
resultados financeiros eles precisam
para atrelado essa solução porque a
gente precisa construir as empresas que
vão funcionar não só agora eu não sou
amanhã não só semana que vem as empresas
que vão funcionar em qualquer situação
na situação que a gente quer construir o
mundo está mudando agora mais do que
nunca numa velocidade acelerada e boas
decisões de negócio consideram todas
essas informações em dentro do processo
de tomada de decisão a gente precisa ter
o máximo de informação sobre as nossas
empresas sobre as nossas vidas sobre as
nossas decisões decisões
bom E com isso também estão incluídos em
informações concretas e sólidas sobre
indicadores de impacto indicadores de
trabalho de solução de problemas Quando
se conecta o discurso com a prática a
gente consegue a minha juntos para esses
caminhos de solução do problema é trazer
e traduzir o discurso que já vem
acontecendo em ações práticas de cada
vez mais velocidade falar sobre mudanças
climáticas dentro de qualquer empresa
falar sobre desigualdade de gênero
desigualdade racial dentro de qualquer
empresa porque esse trabalho não pode
ser um trabalho de um lixo de algumas
poucas empresas a gente tá E é nisso que
eu me mais me identifico no momento em
que a gente precisa convidar convidar
todo mundo se juntar a gente precisa das
empresas grandes a gente precisa das
empresas pequenas a gente precisa das
empresas que estão nascendo para
soluções de problemas
e precisa das empresas que assistiram
como empresas tradicionais só com uma
conexão de todos esses pontos que a
gente consegue caminhar nessa direção a
gente precisa trabalhar junto para isso
aproveitando o poder das empresas e
entendendo que apesar de muito potência
elas nunca serão suficientes sozinho a
gente precisa conectar com você a gente
precisa conectar com academia para
produção de evidência científica desse
trabalho desses resultados a gente
precisa combinar e conectar com ações de
políticas públicas com base de governo
porque só quando a gente junta todo esse
ecossistema a gente consegue caminhar
nessa direção para mim o dinheiro a
compra o investimento a decisão de onde
eu quero trabalhar ela é para mim um
voto de confiança quando a gente passa o
nosso tempo o nosso dinheiro para uma
empresa é também um voto de que você
quer que ela continue fazendo aquilo que
tá acontecendo
e obviamente níveis diferentes de como a
gente pode pressionar e impulsionar
cobrar e pedir convidar essas empresas a
gente precisa que todas as informações
estejam na mesa a luta que é por
transparência a luta aqui é para gente
caminhar em conjunto para essa solução
Ninguém é perfeito eu não sou perfeito
que vocês não são perfeitos porque a
gente precisa é todo todo mundo de
Transparência sobre os nossos problemas
para que a gente fale sobre ele a gente
trabalha só a gente trabalha com eles
para caminhar para o passo onde a gente
quer chegar as empresas que fazem isso
são mais resilientes em tempo de crise
são mais lucrativas e dão mais retorno
sou o prazo quando a gente trabalha para
consolidar uma empresa que é pensada
Para o Futuro no trabalho de atentado
futuro nosso trabalho é o lugar onde eu
quero tá associado lugar onde você
precisa tá buscando
e a gente conectar todas as soluções
quando a gente junta todo mundo em torno
dessa transformação é o ponto em que a
gente consegue a minha é para lá que a
gente tem que ir porque a gente tá de
fato no ponto em que dá para perceber
que o nosso sistema precisa de Ajusta a
gente precisa redefinir nosso sistema
econômico aproveitar todos os avanços
entender e trabalhar com eles para
cuidar desses ajustes que façam para que
a gente arruma a gente a nossa direção
Todo mundo precisa estar junto toda essa
conexão é importante trabalhar com
propósito é trabalhar com a solução
desses problemas é conectar o que você
espera o que você gosta que você quer
você acredita com cada coisa do seu dia
a dia e cada um Cada pessoa tem seu
propósito diferente o importante é que a
gente Connect esse bem-estar e que a
gente cuide para que essa conexão seja
cuidado também de você
a propósito precisa estar conectado com
qualidade compensar vida como um todo é
assim que a gente vai ter na sociedade
em que todo mundo trabalho bem que a
gente caminho para essa solução pensando
em como a gente estrutura as empresas
pensando na governança pensando na
relação com os trabalhadores e com essa
conexão de quanto tá recebendo de quem
são as pessoas como a gente diminui
dessas desigualdades que a gente tem
dentro das nossas estruturas realizadas
tentar como se relacionar com o meu
local como se relaciona com seus
fornecedores com se relaciona com outras
organizações parceiras cuidar do meio
ambiente desde a pegada ambiental até o
seu resultado sair de um estado de só
pensar em fazer o que a permitido por
lei saída esse Impacto não neutro para
atividades práticas e pensar que tudo
que você faz tem impacto nos seus
clientes ou tem Impacto através de um
o meu convite é para que a gente
converse sobre tudo isso que a gente
traga transparência para todos esses
pontos porque a gente se junte para
construir em conjunto eu vou adorar
reforçar e sempre convidar para Que tipo
de conversa seja feita a cada vez mais e
que a gente se junto para caminhar nesta
direção dorme juntos